jean-iv à Mathieu est le nouveau
responsable ivinois de France Parkinson
rien ne transparaît et pourtant à 61 ans
il est atteint depuis 9 mois de la
maladie une pathologie qu'on eu son père
et sa mère ma fille carartophonist m'a
dit un jour en début 2015 oui Jean papa
pardon tu as tu ressembles de plus en
plus à papi donc tu es un peu voûté tu
traînes les pieds tu as les les les bras
qui ne bougent pas quand tu marches et
aut tu devrais consulter il faut se
prépare se préparer à une diminution
DEES de de ses capacités physiques entre
autres et donc il faut faire des choses
moi je vais deux fois par semaine chez
le kiné je vais à la piscine je fais de
la marche et autres c'est dire qu'on se
prépare pour le futur c'est il faut le
faire dès le départ faut le faire quand
on est encore capable de le faire la
maladie de Parkinson est génétique dans
15 % des cas dans les ivelines 3500
personnes en sont atteintes et 350
nouveaux cas détectés chaque année les
premers SIG c'est les raideurs c'est le
les douleurs la raideur dans certaines
choses les bras qui ne balancent pas
quand on marche la perte de l'odorat
aussi des choses qui sont considérées
comme Bénin en temps normal mais qui
peuvent être des bons signes
indicateur cette maladie dite du
mouvement est mal connue pour
l'association il manque de
professionnels de santé correctement
formés le besoin en clair des malades
c'est d'avoir une prise en charge liée
notamment à cette pathologie du
mouvement à ces mouvements qui sont
entravés qui sont gênés et cela veut
dire des
compétences bien sûr neurologique mais
aussi des professions paramédicales
adapté à la pathologie ce qui n'est
aujourd'hui malheureusement pas le cas
c'est attirer l'attention des pouvoirs
publics sur ces besoins qui sont
prignants qui sont extrêmement
importants pour lesquels les malades se
trouvent ce que l'on appelle parfois en
errance médicale la Journée mondiale de
la maladie de Parkinson a lieu le 9
avril ce sera l'occasion pour demander
plus de moyen et mieux faire connaître
la maladie en France 150000 personnes
sont
atteintes